There's an interesting article in vice suggesting
the idea of testing presidential candidates
for cognitive decline.
Executive function is a term, it sounds like
we're talking about CEOs, but what we mean
by executive function, it's a term that is
a, is a collection of cognitive processes
necessary to control behavior.
So very simply it's things like attention
span inhibition.
People should be inhibited to different degrees
depending on the situation in which they find
themselves.
Um, uh, memory, cognitive flexibility.
Each of these has a specific scientific meaning.
There are more and more questions about Donald
Trump's cognitive decline.
A 73 year old man.
There are questions being raised about Joe
Biden that have, uh, come up a 76 year old
man.
There have actually not been any serious questions
about Bernie Sanders cognitive state.
He's 78 years old.
But there is a lot of disagreement about this
because there are those who react and say,
this is an age just idea.
Uh, I don't believe that it is ageist in the
sense that there are a high percentage of
people as they approach 80 years old.
Science tells us this who have some level
of reduced cognitive abilities.
Now I happen to believe that there are also
significant advantages to being more experienced
and having lived more time on this planet
to being president.
And there are areas in fact in which problem
solving with a more, a less judgmental, more
flexible sort of approach, uh, is present
in older folks.
And it is not present in younger folks.
And there are all sorts of arguments that
can be made.
But given the science around it, it doesn't
seem crazy to me, particularly given the behavior
of Donald Trump that we might say, uh, maybe
all candidates should be tested, uh, for a
cognitive decline.
Or, you know, when it comes to driver's licenses,
people start having vision tests and having
to be retested only beyond a certain age.
Some might say 65 or whatever the case may
be.
Now, I know there will be people who watch
this clip or listen to me talking here, and
they'll say, David Trump was screened.
He got the Montreal cognitive assessment and
he's fine.
Now this is nonsense.
The Montreal cognitive assessment is a one
page 30 point test that screens for very specific
and very serious cognitive decline, sometimes
connected to stroke or to certain types of
dementia.
It is completely unsuited for really figuring
out if someone is fit to be president temperamentally
and cognitively and all of these things.
Uh, the Montreal cognitive assessment tests,
visual, visual, spatial, Avila visuospatial
abilities, including for example, saying draw
hands on a paper, on an a, on a drawing clock
for what it looks like when it's two 30 draw
three dimensional cube.
You get six of the 30 points on the Montreal
cognitive assessment just by saying it is,
uh, you know, it is March 5th, and I'm taking
the test in Boston, Massachusetts, for example.
I know it's not March six, then I was actually
in June 10th.
Um, so this is not a test that truly can tell
us whether one's behavior at a more nuanced
level.
One's in ambitions, one's met, one's memory,
etc.
Is suitable to be president of the United
States.
Uh, this is merely about taking seriously
the concerns that anyone who's been paying
attention should have about what's happening
with Donald Trump and arguably with Joe Biden.
There are some questions as well, uh, for
getting Barack Obama's name and we've had
other examples of this.
There are, again, this is not ages.
There are many ways in which older folks are
better thinkers than younger people approaching
problem solving in broader ways.
There's, there's a list of them.
There are nevertheless groups like arp insisting
that this is not something that should be
the focus period, but the president has proven
it should be a focus.
There is confusion.
There is self contradiction.
Trump's visibly confused.
Often he has errors in judgment.
He's spatially confused coming off of Air
Force One, his limo is right in front.
He starts wandering away and has to be pulled
back by secret service on and on and on.
He wants to see the oranges of an investigation.
We have the ability to test for this stuff.
It is not beyond human scope to test for this
stuff.
The test that Donald Trump took, the Montreal
cognitive assessment cannot do it.
It's too low a threshold.
If he was impaired due to stroke or in other
ways the Montreal cognitive assessment might
show it.
It would not show what it is that Trump appears
to be suffering from, but good luck getting
candidates to choose to opt into this type
of testing.
The only way it might be made a universal
is if it's made mandatory.
And that is extraordinarily difficult legally
because the constitution lays out very specifically,
they are simple and basic guidelines.
A citizen and 35, 37 years old, I don't even
remember.
I always get confused between 35 and 37 years
old, I guess it's 35.
Um, but it is extraordinarily difficult from
a legal perspective to add new requirements
or change the requirements to be president
of the United States.
So let me know what you think.
There's really two questions.
Do you believe this is something that should
be done to all some candidates based on age
or no candidates at all?
And if you do believe it's something that
should be done, what is the mechanism through
which it should be done?
Should it be demanded as something that candidates
should merely accept?
Sort of like most candidates up release their
tax returns and financial disclosures.
Should we try to codify it into election law?
Should it be done at the state level?
Sometimes it's believed that states have more
flexibility in terms of imposing additional
requirements like requiring tax returns to
be released to be on the ballot as we are
seeing.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and make sure that you're following me on
twitch at twitch.tv/david Pakman live streams
upcoming this week on twitch